let me say this part two that we don't
give enough value to
um
dude we don't know which person we are
in our
lineage we don't know who we are meaning
you look at i watched the documentary
you read obama's story or kennedy's
story and you see
joseph kennedy has his oldest son joe
and he's planning to build him to be the
president and he ends up going to war
and he dies as a fighter pilot and he
was the guy that was supposed to be then
the kid who had back problems his entire
life who was the youngest one that
nobody expected and the father gave up
on life after the oldest son died he was
depressed for years and the guy that he
least expected to be the president ends
up becoming the president and then you
watch the documentary trumpster there is
the grandfather who comes in who has
restaurants and parlors and all this
stuff i think in alaska out of all the
places literally i think in alaska and
then he
has his son fred trump who moves to
jersey new york he makes us money and
then the grandfather didn't know that
his grandson was one day going to be the
billionaire and
be the president that you don't know the
sacrifice
none of us know what the hell we're here
until we die it's going to take a long
time for you to really realize your
purpose sometimes
god's using you to be the person that
he's counting on for this generation to
do something big with but sometimes he's
using you to breed the person that's
going to end up breeding the person
that's going to end up breeding the
person that's going to be the best
president we've ever had and the
grandfather is never going to know about
it one of the chapels i want to saw in
venice they said this place took 330
years to build the first engineer that
wrote out the map and the the wrote out
the what do you call it the the plan the
plan
the architecture
he knew what he was building his great
great great great great great great
grandkid was never gonna see it can you
imagine you got a vision that you built
something that you're never gonna
fulfill
we forget that sometimes we're just
gonna come and go and it's okay bro be
patient you're just playing a role in
something much bigger that you don't
know about then maybe you if you're
lucky if you are lucky
to see
a part of that become a reality whether
you're being used in a big way or if you
see it happening to your kid and your
grandkid i consider you the luckiest man
or woman alive but if you don't dude you
served your purpose in a different way
you just got to do you so we don't know
this kind of stuff you know we sometimes
we sit there because we tell stories
like this and i sit and talk to my dad
and my dad will go and say
you know he was in love with this one
girl or he wasn't my dad's a romantic
he's a big-time romantic guy and you
know he's he's so i said okay but he
says you know he says to me lately he
says but i tell you what man if i didn't
do that you wouldn't be here paula
wouldn't be here and look where life
would have been and you know i'm so glad
i married your mother because i didn't
even know what was taking place and so
guys as as smart as an intellectual and
crazy we sound and all this we
talk
we don't have a clue what they we got to
do our best with our life that's right
and there's a part of it that you got to
rely on the man upstairs to see what his
plans are and whether you believe in god
or not there's a part of me that just
kind of like you know you still don't
know what's going to happen you don't
know you're going to go
uh uh to louis bossie and you're going
to walk up and the host is going to look
at you you're going to look at her and
all of a sudden you're going to talk to
her and you guys going to exchange
numbers you're going to go to dinner
with her and all of a sudden you're
going to be like i feel something
special with this kid i don't know what
the hell is going on i don't even like
the feeling i got any going to break up
with her and she's going like what are
you doing you have a feeling for me why
are you doing this to yourself six
months 12 months that are you going to
come up to me say pat can we have a
cigar we go to the house well up to
three o'clock in the morning and you say
pat i got feelings for but i'm scared
man we're having that conversation then
you marry her then you have a kid then
you're 82 years old your son ends up
running becoming the president and we
read about it when we're dead
you don't know this kind of stuff that's
why you just gotta sometimes
you know you gotta let it come to you
you gotta
rather than sometimes we put so much
effort before yourself instead of gotta
dance man we gotta dance sometimes so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]